and the Patriots can win with a
touchdown
Birkhead left side clouds into the
and the Patriots have won the AFC
Championship the Patriots have won the
AFC Championship in overtime and the
Chiefs never got a chance to have the
football
that's a little reminder of how the AFC
concluded last year with the Patriots
beating the Chiefs in overtime of the
AFC title game we're going to present to
you now big cats AFC picks minor coming
next week I am procrastinating as long
as I can this is big cats last show
before the season starts so we're gonna
see what he thinks and I'm gonna factor
his views into my own this is just part
of the evidence then I'm compiling
casting a wide net taking in all
opinions and I'll be very interested to
see what big cat has to say let's start
with the AFC East the Patriots the
defending champions who do you like in
that division this year I you would have
to be insane to pick anyone but the
Patriots in the AFC East I know that I
know that people in the media love to do
it they love to say oh this is the year
watch out for the Jets watch out for the
bills watch out for the Dolphins they've
been saying for 15 years well guess what
they're just doing it so that one year
you know in probably ten years when Tom
Brady retires there right just be right
every year and say the Patriots are
gonna win the AFC East so that one was
the easiest one the Patriots are gonna
win the AFC East it reminds me there was
a time 10-15 years ago where there there
was a trend among analysts to pick the
Cardinals to make it to the playoffs
because they were dude they were due
they were due and you just keep picking
the Cardinals every year and they're
finally gonna make it you look like a
genius I think that that's a dynamic
you're right oh the Jets oh I like the
bills I like know if the Patriots I
agree I don't want to tip my pick but
you'd have to be crazy to think the
Patriots aren't gonna win that division
someone whenever the Patriots do not win
the AFC East with Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick which probably won't happen
because they'll retire before it happens
there will be someone trying to take a
victory lap that they were correct that
specific year I need the internet to
find all the times that they were wrong
and pulled the receipts because just
take the Patriots in the AFC he's just
do it yeah it's like the old Chris
Berman perpetual bills 49ers Superbowl
pick he thought eventually he'd get it
right even though it never actually
happened all right
AFC North who do you have coming out of
that division which but for the Bengals
has three teams that could win the title
yeah so everyone obviously loves the
Browns people think that the Steelers
are gonna bounce back with maybe Antonio
Brown off the team a little less
but I'm going with the Ravens I think
the defense and I actually I'm not a
huge believer in the Marg accent as a
thrower yet but I think he is the whole
package is special he's not he's got to
get there in the throwing side
I like the Ravens I think they are going
to win the AFC north and I just
something about the Ravens when their
defense gets cooking it's just a
different style of defense they had the
second best defense last year I think
there that's gonna happen again this
year behind the Bears so I'm taking the
Ravens in a very tough to win AFC North
you know the one thing about the Ravens
that that has me not concerned but
hesitant I don't know what the offense
is going to be and I have a feeling that
that offense is going to be different
every week that that's what they're
trying to setup here and if Lamar
Jackson can throw at a respectable level
they can design a game plan each week
based upon what they've maybe set the
next opponent up to think they're going
to do and maybe they think they see a
weakness they can run the ball they can
throw the ball they want to have that
versatility week in and week out drive
in and drive out to really keep you on
your heels guessing what they're gonna
do offensively and it's work so far
because we don't know what they're gonna
look like I don't know that I'm gonna
pick the Ravens but I I think as we get
closer and closer to the start of the
season it makes sense to take them
seriously because I feel like they're
not just bluffing here they got
something up their sleeve that they
think is gonna be good and when you see
what John Harbaugh has done for his
career as the head coach of that team
it's hard to doubt him this time around
alright
AFC South we talked about them in the
little TV only stuff that we did before
we came back from the radio break who do
you like coming out of that division
which got jumbled with Andrew Luck
retiring last weekend yeah I would have
picked Andrew Luck in the Colts if this
was being taped last Friday but because
he has retired I'm gonna take the
Jaguars we talked about it with Nick
Foles I think Nick Foles transforms that
team I think the team that you saw two
years ago where they were dominant on
the defensive side of the ball
Josh Allen is an absolute stud and
instant game changer for the
Jacksonville Jaguars so I'm taking the
Jaguars to win the AFC South to get
their mojo back I have never been a
believer in the Texans I
famously bet the tip of my pinky they
wouldn't win the Super Bowl last year
I'm gonna still not be a believer in the
Texans I love Mike variable but I can't
figure out what's going on in Tennessee
in the quarterback situation he needs a
quarterback before he's gonna win the
AFC South so I'm taking the Jaguars are
you putting the tip of your pinky on it
again this year about the Texans not
winning the Superbowl there will be a
pinky bet we will decide after week
three so stay tuned all right oh and oh
and we will and I agree with you on the
Jaguars I think that they are going to
turn it around dramatically I think last
year was an aberration I really think
that what happened was they beat the
Patriots week two they were to a no they
just wanted to fast-forward to the
playoffs and they forgot that hey week
in and week out you got to show up and
win football games and if you don't the
next thing you know you're 5 and 11 and
they didn't they didn't have that same
sense of discipline that they had in
2017 I think they get it back this year
especially because some jobs are on the
line in the front office and in the
coaching staff if they don't all right
last division in the in the AFC AFC West
Chiefs of the defending champions do
they repeat yes they repeat the Chiefs
repeat this is another one that don't
overthink it obviously there's some
questions with their defense but that
offense is so explosive it will have no
problem winning 12 13 games probably
winning probably getting the number one
seed or number two seed because it we're
gonna preview here what I have in my
playoffs but yeah the Chiefs
just take them Patrick mahomes special I
know everyone's saying well maybe he
goes backwards a little bit from his
fantastic MVP season last year I don't
see it I think he's gonna be just as
special I think that offense is gonna be
just as explosive so take the Chiefs
don't even think about it if you're
watching on NBCSN or Sky Sports you see
footage of the drive that patrick holmes
had against the bengals in the first
preseason game and it was it didn't feel
like the preseason the pre seasons got
kind of a weird like it's it's you know
it's not like regular see like yeah it's
just kind of they're testing things it
was back to just what they were last
year right down the field here's the
Chiefs offense and the defense can't get
any worse if they only get a little bit
better they go to the Super Bowl so yeah
you know it's it's a fool's errand to
try to be that day if I had that hot
take artist that says the Chiefs aren't
gonna make it to the playoffs this year
I think the Chiefs even more certain to
win the division than the Patriots are
to win the AFC East all right two
wild-card teams big cat who do you have
all right so my two wild-card teams I
wanted to go with one team that I feel
very confident will be in the playoffs
and one a little outside the box this is
where I'm going outside the box so I
have the Browns coming out of the AFC
North I think they will go nine and
seven or ten and six and make that
wild-card spot and I have the New York
Jets that's my wild wild card pick I
like the Jets I do not think they're
gonna win the AFC East I do think they
will be able to be competitive and slip
into that last wild card and this is
more actually an indictment on the
Chargers and the Steelers than it is a
pro Jets because I think the Chargers
every year feels like there's a big
injury Derwin James already out i I just
every year I think the Chargers are
gonna do it a couple of these
quarterbacks Mike are going to fall off
a cliff at some point it happens
overnight
remember the Peyton Manning his last
year when everyone thought that oh my
gosh he's been terrible the way Peyton
Manning's career ended that season where
he went off the cliff he was great at
the beginning of that season and then it
went off the cliff and I think it's a
long season you saw a little bit with
Drew Brees last year so I think you're
gonna get a little bit of that with the
Chargers so Jets Browns in the wild-card
even that last season for Peyton Manning
when he was okay physically or at least
seemed okay physically someone that I
know saw him in the hallway at I assume
the the week one game at Mile High
Stadium and and just doing everything he
could to like loosen up his back doing
all these weird funky exercises to get
himself ready it was the first game of
the season and they did they barely held
him together they benched him for a
while either he was injured or
ineffective or whatever but you're right
it can't happen quickly it doesn't
happen in the offseason all the time it
happens during that four month grind and
Phillip Rivers said something a few
weeks back that caught my attention they
were twelve and four last year he said
we could have been 16 - no we could have
been six and 10 a lot of close games and
this year teams are going to take them
more seriously this year they get a
little more high
behind them losing Derwin James hurts
and I tend to agree with you I think
that there's gonna be a dip for the
Chargers and I'm glad that my mice not
so subtle hyping of the Jets crept
through it got you to think outside the
box he's box here and you're out here
yeah I cuz I believe the Jets can do it
I think either the Jets of the bills
will take one of those wild card spots
and I think between the two the Jets are
more likely Mike don't flatter yourself
I watched I bet the Falcons first half
line against the Jets I think was week
two preseason and the Jets absolutely
mauled them from that point forward I
was a believer all right do you have a
seating for the six teams that you've
put in the playoffs no I do not I do not
have a seating let's just go to the a
let's fast-forward to the AFC
Championship game all right who do you
have let me guess Patriots Chiefs
Patriots Chiefs and I have the Chiefs
winning this one so I think the Chiefs
will find a way to win the AFC
championship against the Patriots the
Patriots interesting enough the thing
that doesn't get talked about Tom Brady
obviously he is the greatest quarterback
of all time six rings all these
accolades he wasn't that great in the
playoffs after that Chargers game where
he picked apart that Chargers defense
and they absolutely destroyed them but
that that Chiefs AFC championship game
if Dee Ford isn't offsides and I know
don't play the what if game everything
but if D for it is an offsides which is
just one play Tom Brady loses an AFC
championship game with one touchdown in
three interceptions the Super Bowl was a
grind a defensive slugfest and the Rams
should get a lot of credit for playing
fantastic defense but he wasn't special
he wasn't fantastic he made the big
throws when he had to so the question is
is Tom Brady in that category of guys
where you it will happen overnight and
he will still be able to make the
special throws and he will still be able
to make the big-time moments like in the
overtime against the Chiefs but it's
it's one of those things that's slippery
I think the Chiefs will will be able to
ascend pass them this year go to the
Super Bowl I think the key is deliver
the knockout punch before Tom Berg
can morph into that guy who makes the
big throw when he has to write be up by
14 17 20 points too late in the game for
Brady to do anything about it that ya
the AFC championship game if you go back
and look the Chiefs sort of they lost
that game in the first half when their
offense never got going they picked it
up in the second half it all started to
click but they were not able to get it
going early I think they even started
the game I might be you know I'm
remembering correctly I think they
started the game with a three and out
like that's the kind of stuff when
you're at home and you have the best
offense in the league and the Patriots
come in that's where Bill Belichick and
Tom Brady if you give them an inch
they'll take a mile if you give you just
slip up a little bit so I think the
Chiefs get those slip-ups fix them and
they will win and go to the Super Bowl
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports